6 février 1934
depuis des mois les français vous voyez
des perrières la france les mots sacrés
perdu leur sens la tradition était sapé
l'honneur n'était plus qu'un accessoire
la patrie ne venaient plus qu'au
quatrième ou cinquième rang derrière
l'individu le camarade la combine
c'était il ya cinquante ans le 6 février
1934 mesdames messieurs bonsoir
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui est
celle ci y at-il ou non un renouveau de
l'extrême droite
nous sommes ici rue du clos non le 20e
arrondissement à paris
à quelques mètres de là à l'école
communale
c'est le bureau de vote où le front
national de jean marie le pen a réussi
le score le plus important qu'il est eu
pu obtenir en france 17 points 17 points
par rapport aux deux ou trois points
qu'obtient ordinairement l'extrême
droite en france cela pose question
vous avez accepté deux d'être
interviewés à condition de ne pas être
identifiée vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi parce que maintenant le racisme
c'est un mot qui est galvaudé on est
raciste pour un oui pour un non
vous votez pour qui bah c'est suivant je
vote
opportuniste l'open et avant bas avant
j'ai voté mitterrand et danse les
slogans de jean marie le pen et du front
national vous vous retrouvez bas sur
l'immigration seulement pour ça vous
êtes quelqu'un donc à droite
non
français simplement vous faites un
travail très pénible
je suis joueur actuel moyens beaucoup
plus pour le faire des français combien
gagnez-vous 5500 note
qu'est ce que vous reprochez le plus aux
immigrés en france
ce que je crois c'est c'est une sur
plante est ce qu'on majoritaire en plus
que ça c'est un jour ils votent alors
niveau trop toujours pour l'intérêt de
leur pays avant avant celui de la france
même s'ils s'en font même nom 600
français même s'ils sont naturalisés ça
changera rien du tout actuellement les
juifs il y votent pour israël si un jour
les arabes et si un jour les avis ils se
mettent à voter
ok qui votons ils voteront pour le pour
la cause arabe la cause musulmane c'est
évident vous travaillez avec des
immigrés est-ce qu'il y en a qui habite
à côté de chez vous à côté de votre
appartement
oui là pas de problème
vous ne détestez pas bon
pas encore peut-être que ça viendra
parce qu'un jour et la cohabitation
ça se passera pas toujours bien vous
n'avez pas peur qu'un jour il y ait des
affrontements ici à cause de ce genre de
discours
enfin que cela provoque la haine
hélas oui c'est possible ça commence
déjà
vous êtes prêt à vous organiser avec
d'autres français
ça dépend ça dépend pour quoi vous
trouvez que le pen va assez loin ou pas
dans son discours sur l'immigration
non c'est juste c'est juste c'est
parfait c'est juste qu'est ce qu'il faut
dire
décembre 1983 nous commençons un étrange
voyage au coeur même de la france
nous entendons des mots délit de sale
gueule défense de l'occident
il y a neuf mois précédé de slogans tels
que deux millions de chômeurs 2 millions
d'immigrés en trop les français d'abord
jean marie le pen leader du front
national obtient 12 % de voix dans le
20e arrondissement de paris la famille g
ils sont tous les trois militants du
front national pas de diesel
traditionnel
chacun peut préférer la babouche qui
rend chez la coiffeuse qui poussent
autour du [ __ ] et hilton papier tu te
regardes vous êtes du côté des numéros
pairs
le bureau de cette dette sociale et du
côté des numéros impairs l'armement
sociale je viens de vous dire que vous
êtes du côté des ming pei l'aide sociale
elle est aux 45
du côté des numéros impairs sociale
elle lui fait signer un sort dehors qui
a lui fait signe là-bas c'est tout puis
elle rentre indices il m'a montré un
papier de la mairie mérite paris sur
lequel était inscrit chers collègues je
vous envoie cet homme c'est un algérien
il n'a pas de papiers voyez ce que vous
pouvez faire pour lui quand on vous dit
que l'immigration est allaité india il
ne parlait pas un mot de français
le seul mot qui savait dire social le
20e arrondissement à l'autre bout de
paris monsieur g va nous faire visiter
son quartier le pari qu'il inquiète
monsieur j'ai fait partie des 12 %
d'électeurs qui aux municipales de mars
dernier ont permis à jean-marie le pen
de devenir conseiller dans le 20e
arrondissement sont américains qui est
venu à paris ils étaient semées
déciderait service devient c'est
incroyable et je pensais pas qu'elles
les français qui sont obsédés qu'ils
sont absentés de
de france pour quelques années qu'ils
reviennent dans ses relances ont tout à
fait surpris moi même qui suis un
militant du quartier qui suit l'appui
depuis vingt ans j'ai constaté une
évolution
considérable c'est à dire quand je suis
arrivé ici il y avait des défis pavillon
c'était la campagne si d'ailleurs hier
une partie du xxème s'appelle la
campagne à paris et puis peut un peu le
les vagues d'émigration
c'est à déferler sont en redressement
c'est ainsi que mon fils tu es à l'école
de la rue sorbier et bien les deux tiers
les deux tiers des élèves disent prendre
sa classe b drilles étrangères il ne
faisait pas beaucoup de progrès en
français mais par contre en portugais
renard a commencé à avoir des
connaissances certaines est alors pour
que mon fils puisse apprendre la langue
de ses ancêtres pièces n'étaient pas
forcément dans mes convictions celle
d'une bête dans une école d'ingé nicole
dumont
m
je ne
non
oh
c'est pas aller dans un pays
démocratique un problème je pense que je
pense qu'on aura alors franchement c'est
pas sûr pourquoi vous n'êtes pas sûrs
comme ça l'idée
c'est le gérant était là il avoue marie
la porte merci j'étais comptable
après je vais travailler dans une agence
immobilière je suis venu administrateurs
de biens je franchissais 3 tous les
échelons je crois que je fais bien mon
métier ça fait 25 ans que je suis
commerçant et les gens qui me prend
confiance en pascal rabaté je ne suis
pas inquiet je suis dégoûté si je suis
un bourgeois
je suis un petit bourgeois france à ça
je le pense oui franchement
d'abord je suis aussi loin que je
regarde derrière moi je ne vois que des
ancêtres français d' aide alors même pas
des petits bourgeois des petits paysans
de la corrèze qui devaient travailler
très dur pour arriver à vivre
si vous deviez finalement faire une
espèce de de récapitulatif des vertus
qu'il vous semblent les plus fortes
celle que vous préférez eh bien écoutez
et les vertus moi je parle pas des
retouches par la liberté alors la
liberté celle qui en tout cas ont guidé
votre vie je pense vous cela la loyauté
l'honnêteté le travail
je sais que et le sens de l'honneur tout
ce qui est complètement perdue en france
même temps quelqu'un d'autre a pu dire
joue ne pardonnent alors ça fait
ridicule mais moi quand je donne cette
parole mais cette part l'appareil moi
c'est sérieux mais sachez bien sûr sont
des valeurs valeurs qui sont pires il
est maintenant le patriotisme
on parle maintenant beaucoup la suite
travail famille patrie
attention vous savez le maréchal pétain
n'avait rien inventé travail famille
patrie ce sont des valeurs qui sont
appréciées des français depuis des
siècles et sous tous les régimes
quand un peuple connaît d'une période
difficile comme c'était le cas pendant
l'occupation il se raccroche aux
branches merci h à ses racines et à ce
moment là travail famille patrie c'était
la seule chose qu'on pouvait offrir aux
français ils avaient tout perdu
il est occupé par la parler par là par
l'ennemi ce sont des valeurs qui sont
appréciés également dans d'autres pays
notamment en union soviétique si je
comprends bien je voudrais leur entrain
de faire un parallèle entre la situation
de 1940 et aujourd'hui voulait dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut se raccrocher à
ces valeurs là oui parce que aujourd'hui
qu'en dix ans 1949 travail je suis un
résistant au laxisme
je suis un résistant à l'invasion dans
le monde paye et d'objets ce qui me
plaît beaucoup dans le programme de
jean-marie le pen c'est qu'il a dit
les français d'abord à ma connaissance
c'est le seul homme politique ait dit ça
monsieur g nous entraîne à quelques pas
de chez lui dans les bureaux de l'anpe
pour lui il y à là la preuve évidente
qu'il a raison il y a trop d'immigrés en
france et on cache la vérité aux
français
c'est du moins son point de vue
bien sûr monsieur vous avez tout autour
d'agencés dernier bureau à votre endroit
toujours là bas
monsieur non métier ce qui m'a plu c'est
que non mais vous avez vu l'accueil qui
nous a été réservé on nous a mis à la
porte on a refusé de donner des
précisions de mendiants savoir le nombre
de travailleurs immigrés qui sont un
scandale que si on refuse de nous donner
ces précisions et que c'est parce que
ces précisions sont gênantes
samedi 3 décembre 1983 à l'angle du
boulevard de belleville et de la rue de
ménilmontant
un des points chauds du 20e
arrondissement pour en savoir un peu
plus nous endossons les habits
provocateur des membres d'une
association que nous avons créé pour ce
reportage
l'association de défense des français de
france
la caméra est cachée au deuxième étage
d'un immeuble avec notre acte n'aura
colons nos premiers français de france
nous interrogeons des français si nous
les langues vont se délier 400 épreuve
de commutation la caméra
tu vois ici
j'ai appris les questionnaires
monsieur madame vous êtes des habitants
du quartier est-ce que vous avez
conservé que votre quartier allait
changer au cours des dernières années et
pas en bien
c'est à dire que tout a changé le monde
la mentalité
les commerçants tout a changé la
malpropreté
et ça c'est lié à quoi vous avez je ne
sais pas si la terre est à tout mais
vraiment ils mettront un peu plus de 50
% d'immigrés
c'était pour un thème tout droit de
vivre pour blanc ce qu'ils ont dit que
ça change et vous un peu votre veste ou
pas oh non au contraire ça me va
renforcer de ce que je me tais avant
pensez bien que je me cache pas je suis
repérera
ce que voulait pour vous madame
merci et bon week-end
bon je vais mettre ici je vais vous
demander votre alger 50 16 ans
quel est votre profession vous êtes en
ce moment vous êtes inscrits à l'anpe en
prime ils sont sans rien vous ne touchez
à rien pour quelles raisons là parce que
j'ai dépassé des dîners chics ma pension
de travail vous pensez que votre mode de
vie s'est dégradée est-ce que vous
presque mille six cent mille francs par
mois maintenant il en fait elle est
dégradée un jeu payant oui quand même à
85 le plus ma femme est handicapée
elle reçoit quelque chose là et 100000
frontier donc vous vivez avec 2000
francs paru en 2000 francs bah moi est
ce qu'un parti politique actuellement
qui correspond à vos amis qui dit des
choses en tout cas avec lesquels vous
êtes d'accord moi je veux un truc par
exemple mais elle va du communisme il
suit à gauche
le plus dur était vous êtes des deux
tubes préfère le parti communiste c'est
toujours pareil il faut pas partir et ce
à la tête de soudain un peul laurent
d'accord mais pas marché vous êtes parti
communiste
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de décider
par exemple de le pen en face de ces
problèmes d'immigration le pen il est
pas mal de vouloir virer les étrangers
mais ça ne sera pas une solution pour
que ça ne sera pas une solution pour
quelles raisons là pour la reine ont des
gueules on dit donc en prendre
les lions veulent plus travailler dans
la demo qui va là où les gars quand le
bâtiment va tout ce qu'il dira c'est
tout qui se tapent en appel il est bien
compris mais après avoir démonté n'ai
pas été tenté de voter pour lui la aux
dernières élections au sénat parce que
non encore une qui avait été alors
répondu que pour lui parce qu'il a
hérité des communistes qui va être pour
les revues peut-être possible le fait
bien possible c'est de la légitime
défense
nishi sourd on n'est pas au loup en
l'épaule ou santé en péril
justin que la fonction déperdition de
votre commande
voir mon père qui essaient de faire
baisser de voir il va à l'étranger
vivent aussi dans un autre nasri cahill
par la france mais alors qu'est-ce que
c'est la france bleu en 2000 et ça s'est
démis j'aurais pas 40
vous connaissez jean marie le pen et le
front national
vous pensez que vous connaissez son
attitude et sa vision de la situation de
millions ça vous connaissez son slogan 2
millions de chômeurs du million
d'immigrants qui vous trouvez que c'est
vrai c'est pas moi c'est plus qu'un vrai
parce que les choses soient remises en
ordre
sa remise en ordre comme elle devrait
beaucoup il dit je suis un français
bruns chauds mais elle est même arrivée
est un français parfait a guère tout
staff français 14 18 personnes étaient
là pour me garer nos appareils aux
dernières élections vous avez voté pour
qui à gauche ou à droite à gauche ou à
droite simplement à pas pour tian son
fils aime ma condition sociale je leur
dis comme ça il n'aurait pas dû voter
comme vous avez voté à trois conditions
c'est ça si je parle de catégories
sociales taulier du voter à gauche et
vous n'avez pas l'hôtel
actuellement ce qui seront bientôt de
commandes marc et jean marie le pen
quand on en dise c'est des gens qui
n'ont pas d'argent qui votent pour lui
parce qu'il vivait avec savent ce que
c'est les saisons des panneaux thaksin
c'est comme ça il faut être très franc
vous voulez dire que vous avez voté pour
jean marie le pen atteint tous ces
anonymes
vous avez voté pour le front national
est un parti dont vous pensez qu'ils
défendent nos intérêts avec le mois et
absolue qui est réaliste
c'est quand même étrange en fait vous
êtes une femme de droite on en arrive à
quoi les varois alors oui oui c'est
l'autre journaliste de vivre que vous
avez eue hier soir mais en fait on a un
petit peu on a un petit peu réfléchi
votre témoignage serait quand même
important alors qu'elle est le en fait
quelle est la raison qui vous ont ils
enfin y'a pas de problème ils vont pas
venir avant de réactions violentes où
vous avez le droit de dire pour qui vous
votez c'est en partie les gars dans sa
thématique match contre les émirats sont
pas bêtes jamais moi sur mon palier qui
fait drôle de tête parce qu'il peut s'en
douter
pourquoi je suis là ensemble votre
entourage un petit peu les étages où il
habitait à ces dix tunisiens
c'est pas des gens dangereux
je pense à banaliser 6 cd et français tu
disais à tout ça s'est fait désirer
c'est pas des français c'est toute seule
la française mme peel et tous les minces
et des noirs d'aider des zones est ce
que vous voulez
enfin vous savez si vous simplifie vous
expliquer simplement pourquoi vous avez
envie de voter pour quoi vous voter pour
jean marie le pen pourquoi vous avez
voté pour lui aux dernières élections
qui pourraient nettoyer la france je
pense quand même que vous avez eu des
ennuis vous avez perdu
j'en ai jamais monsieur pourquoi
pourquoi vous dérange-t-il au logement
pour allons tout de suite bien logement
pour une main ma fille ça fait trois ans
qu'elle atteint logements 304 qu'elle
attend qu'elle a un taquet cannes est
aussi formidable elle et les petites
filles sa petite-fille j'ai tout bien
madame d et la rumeur dit encore
beaucoup de choses par exemple que 70 %
d'étrangers habite là non pas dans les
taudis du quartier en cours de
démolition mais dans ces immeubles
modernes construits il ya quatre ans par
la ville de paris
c'est encore au bureau de vote de
l'école maternelle de la rue du clos
qu'aux municipales jean marie le pen a
fait son plus gros score 20 % de voix le
député rpr pdg de l'hebdomadaire jours
de france marcel dassault ne nous
contredira sûrement pas les vérités
sortent parfois du café du commerce
il est 11 heures du matin au trou
normand rue du clos moi je dit de toute
façon joie de samedi noir comme ça ça
fera chez tout le monde du quartier
voilà ça fait sans fin je regardais bois
tordus en moi je trouve jamais devant
les églises dans les boîtes ordures
trouvait petit mon point dis moi moi je
vais répondre qu'est ce que c'est clos
peine
exactement je vais au maximum droit mais
qu'est ce que c'est le matanais cette
droite qui est est ce que les décrets
d'abord et le nom de connery
attention je ne déteste ni les émigrés
ni des zones de mon l'heure j'ai dit que
la seule chose en france que tout le
monde à droite vivent sur terre on est
tous des êtres humains on a le droit de
vivre mais que ce quand même qui sont au
chômage depuis deux trois ans da ces
gens là quand ils volent sans travail on
doit les renvoyer chez 2 est bien de
commercy du travail quand vous emmène
pas d'accord faisait barrage et il te
fait rire quand c'est dit qu'on n'a pas
voulu me faire 80 heures de travail et
quand mon mari était pas malade j'ai pas
besoin de travailler travail elle était
la ville de paris elle coûte hamouda un
algérien ya trente ans en arrière je me
rappelle gitane à jerry moyes un bon qui
sait qu'ils étaient français là ben ben
c'était nous voit les européens n'aura
pas je regrette mais quand on prend des
coups fin picavet la queue et qu'on
passait parce qu'on était européenne
on était servi tout de suite hein tu
branches - en france on les appelle et
conférant les appelle pas des émigrés on
va sûrement pas je pars vivish quand je
veux moi bah oui je filais moi tu n'es
mère juive - voilà je renie pas marrade
et ça n'empêche pas que j'ai un vieux
con comme toi un arabe parce que dans ma
jeunesse c'est pas les juifs qui m'ont
donne à bouffer c'est les arabes
jeudi mais annette moi d'abord de toute
façon le français c'est des connards ils
votent pas n'importe qui pour n'importe
quoi moi quand je me mets à la fenêtre
d'été je suis content que moi parce
qu'un jour je suis en chine
le lendemain à chaud en afrique hall
sûrement dachau en algérie elle passait
bien
j'ai même pas besoin de me payer de
vacances je me suis engagé à 18 ans à la
guerre du rif
les inconnus ou là alors oui je m'en
rappelle ne pousse les prix de l'art eu
des bonnes femmes des bonnes femmes qui
avaient pu se pendre
peut-être qu'il a une [ __ ] en plus rien
il te les prenait que les violets les
français l'espace et c'était honteux
honteux faire des choses pareilles
moi je me souviens et à ce moment là
nous avons le temps c'était l'âge d'or
en france étaient là encore on mange
éléments du tout ça qui parlent et
qu'ils soient là c'est en fait dont les
accords reich
on les accueille mais de là à ce qu'ils
viennent revendiquer tell tale août
ajoute ou alors venir démoli en note
pauline annoncé au bout d'un combat pour
d'accord voici sont pas contents s'ils
sont contents de venir ici qu'ils
essayent en otage
pourquoi ils sont chez nous pourquoi
vous êtes chez nous parce que nous aussi
on vous l'a prouvé qu'à man quand
creuser la terre qu'on faisait des
routes parce que tous ces gars-là rond
les employés écoutons les a employées
bataille
ils ont un peu la sécurité de l'emploi
on va maintenant on peut même pas mettre
un immigré à la porte parce que y aller
faire du camp il ya tout facile qui vont
nous rentrer dedans on va pas le mettre
à la porte pour embaucher un pauvre
français qui fera peut-être content de
venir dans ce derby des pouilles je
serai peut-être content mais sur un jeu
manquant vous allez faire alors un
garçon du même âge que je suis arrivé
j'avais 17 ans excusez moi mais
maintenant j'y suis content qu'elle
avait en fait l'algérie mois n'est pas
candidat c'est braaten je rende à perdre
tous mes droits
trente trois ans que je verse les
caisses françaises mais tu veux mais tu
travailles pendant ce temps-là tu
touches de l'argent tant d'envié chez
toi tu as fait vite de tafer vivre sa
famille mais non je n'ai pas visé la
famille changé leur trajet toi je vais
te sert à quoi sont parmi les chrétiens
je paie la pièce de viège suisse allait
bâtir un vieux garçon adossé les jeux
bennati de viège et paul goureman
je tiens le coche en femme égale preuves
ou jeu pour vous le prouver mais j'ai ma
comptabilité un commerce ce sont des
constantes alors quand tu as pris ton
commerce une savait que ça allait payer
on a dit tout ce que tu avais a payé
peut-être des gens très jaloux des gens
qu'ils arrivent à quelque chose
certes ou majorité actuelle toute la
saveur ne l'attendait pas le monde mais
on l'avait déjà consulté oui on apprend
comment je veux dire il y en avait moins
il y aurait peut-être moins de moins de
racisme aussi tu prends la place de la
réunion tu prends n'importe quelle heure
de la journée
la petite qui sait que tu vois devant
devant les bars devant n'importe quoi en
train de faire le bon traduire les dames
et messieurs c'est quoi c'était dans la
cgt à nice en lente et de force a
traversé une frontière oui mais c'est
ses deux grands rivaux de france élite
en effet enseignons le pauvre mec le
pauvre mec qui est en train de se casser
toute la journée à botter piqué voit ces
mecs en train de faire le lédat rue
les idées du front national ça me semble
plutôt réinstallant à 10 ans est poussé
à l'extrême
bah c'est trop il se passe avec rimbaud
on peut pas renvoyer tout le monde s'est
dit on a eu besoin parfois les matches
tous les sens d'emploi tous les sans
domicile et tout ça à faire je fais un
petit qu un petit compte rendu de la
chose et tout bon il y en a peut-être
fait rien on a peut-être un tiers a
envoyé un de renvoyer les gens facile
dès l'instant qu'ils sont là comme des
sons la charge pas évolué du feu à
charge dans leur pays que chez nous mais
toi tu en bien d'autres choix
on est tous des métis bordel moi je suis
breton et mois çi polonais devra les
camps de concentration je connais ça
quand j'avais 20 ans tu vas j'ai regardé
des films d'alain resnais la nuit bien
et chacun son poids légers vul n
architectes nazis qui s'extasiaient
devant la beauté de fours crématoires
fallait brûler tous les juifs
on a brûlé 6000 juifs 6 millions d uc
dans le pays on n'avait pas des
[ __ ] avec lé juif on a fait des
pauvres
bravo mais dans ce cas là on peut on
peut remonter jusqu'à l'envié toi tu es
métis le condenseur romain qui sont
montés
la whey bah oui à ça commence ou assas
terminaux l'histoire je suis ravi la vie
tel est lé 20e monsieur le pen fait 10
pour 17%
bravo monsieur le pen dommage qu'il a
vendu son bond au mondial diana avant il
était plus beau avec son oeil les beurs
vous avez la trouille bordel français
moyens vous avez la trousse vous
cherchez un patin d'école pour vous
sauver un hitler à lapins hitler en
france malheureusement
mais si chirac c'était l'enfant des
cailleras messieurs les pins c'est un
con quand je vois les bastions
communistes qui tangue parce que
français moyens ils rêvent d trouve un
papa un papa qui va les sauver de la
merde habitations mais quand il faut
faire des égouts un coulage du béton
creusa je suis dans les bâtiments ou les
faire découvrir ramasser les poubelles
non mais vous avez beau jeu de parler
vous creusez vous tuez g même un jeu
pascal aujourd'hui dans les poubelles et
marche pas les avoir dans les poubelles
c'est tout j'ai fait les poubelles jouer
ici c'est ce qu'annonçait le pays on
peut vivre me sentais plus rien dans les
poubelles dans chercher ailleurs
haier sais où tu veux m'en voyante
pologne 1 6 1
tu vas aujourd'hui en fait tampon
l'anniversaire parce que des connards
les ouvriers qui ont ras-le-bol d'un
pinot chez polonais aux yeux noirs tu
vas général jaruzelski qui a fait ses
études à moscow même je n'ai rien à
[ __ ] moi de l'est vraiment tu regarde
ta boutique vous êtes pouces n'est pas
des boutiquiers d'hérens balade des
boutiques immersion béninois yaya rien
avec qu'est ce que vous faites ici à
leur collège un juge le droit de me
promener la réparation des droits des
modèles à emmener vous amusez vous mais
venez pas m'emmerder cette omerta mais
quand ses chances valoir à coup
tranquille alors lé coach breton frère
un coup aussi
paris xxème arrondissement dans la cité
hlm de la rue du clos enfin une porte va
s'ouvrir en mars dernier madame à à
voter pour jean marie le pen
madame à et mère de deux enfants son
mari et ouvriers charcutier leurs
revenus mensuels 8000 francs environ
vous situer plutôt à gauche ou à droite
puis à gauche
malgré tout on voit ça de toute manière
je ne revoterai pas à droite malgré ce
qu'on vit en ce moment je n'en verrai
sûrement pas à droite un je vous dis je
préfèrerais encore voter blanc que
nouveauté à droite c'est pas la peine de
retourner en arrière on sait ce qu'on a
perdu ce qu'on a eu c'est pas la peine
d'y retourner
je vous dis donc quand j'ai voté le pen
c'était nerveux parce que ce que j'y
connais rien en politique tout ce que
c'est bon c'est que je préfère encore
rester à gosses que dans les extrêmes
j'irai pas non plus voté extrême mouche
j'ai pas extrémiste se définir ce que
ces personnes note pour vous je lui dis
je fais pas de politique alors je serai
divisible je connais pas grand chose ou
bien
bon à part que je sais que j'ai entendu
à la radio et tout après j'ai lu c'est
un certain article je me suis rendu
compte que le pen c'est un fasciste
moi je n'ai pas non plus à voter pour ce
genre de deux personnes mais on va pas
retourner faut pas avoir à nouveau un
nouvel hitler quand même je crois que le
temps est passé non quand vous dites que
pour vous le pen et fasciste raciste en
vie
vous pouvez expliquer ça ça s'explique
pas il l'a choisi il pense lorsqu'il
pense à l'huile le pensez vous je pense
pas pareil
est-ce que vous pensez que les valeurs
travail famille patrie sont des valeurs
de gauche ou des valeurs de droite vous
êtes déjà un travailleur oui oui ça on
travaille pour y arriver
vous avez manqué où il a émis le souhait
parce que quand vous regardez à droite à
la limite c'est pour sii famille famille
et puis voilà que c'est enfin c'est fou
que ça à droite bien sont les gens
riches qui équivaut de la droite à
préserver leur budget et on a qu'à voir
maintenant non quand on est sous un
gouvernement de gauche tout l'argent
sans argent allez les gens riches
placent leur argent ailleurs pour ça
qu'on a tant de problèmes je pense je
connais pas grand chose et famille vous
êtes aussi pour la famille oui bon
enfant vous n'êtes pas beaucoup ça que
je trouve un peu riant la notion de
famille la notion de faire des enfants
de
de la solidarité familiale sont des
valeurs auxquelles vous vous référez oui
bah oui j'ai des enfants vous en ferez
d'autres non non je présence de les
avoir mais je pense à leur avenir leur
avenir il est pas beau les grands pas
beau parce que justement on nous demande
de faire des enfants
quand on voit le nombre de chômeurs kia
ça laisse à réfléchir
je tiens pas en avoir 8-9 même trois ans
et je n'ai même pas jusqu'à 3 j'en ai
deux ça me fait plaisir d'aller vers 2
mais il faut les élever maintenant dans
mon travail mais et puis patrie ou tout
au moins nations la france c'est une
valeur qui vous semblent importantes ou
pas valeur j'ai pas dans quel sens que
vous l'entendez évidemment je suis en
france je suis française j'irai par
ailleurs j'irai pas dans un autre pays
parce que je suis française racines des
puits mais plus vous lisent mais c'est
important pour moi la patrie mais disons
qu'elle me permet de vivre si tout ça va
plus je n'ai pas ce sentiment de lui
devoir quelque chose non pas du tout non
je pense que c'était cuit mendois après
tout qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
morceau de terre on va j'y suis né j'y
reste givi suivi tant bien que mal
je lui dois rien mais elle a des devoirs
vous avez du goût des trois devis vous
vous avez des droits sur m
oui je pense lesquels
mais dix ans que j'apporte j'apporte
quelque chose en travaillant j'apporte
mes enfants je pense que elle me doit
quelque chose c'est pas évident de vie
des enfants d'avoir les enfants de
travailler pour la france
après tout je paye mes impôts je paye la
sécu beaucoup de trop je lui dois rien
après tout que ce soit ici ou ailleurs
sont que jaurès en france parce que
c'est ma langue sa vie de dénis grèce et
je me vois pas émigrer doit réapprendre
autres ont à vivre autrement quoi c'est
tout est ce que vous pensez qu'avec ces
valeurs là travail et famille vous
n'êtes plus proche de la gauche ou de la
droite de jean marie le pen dont ce sont
des valeurs référence non non non je
suis plus proche de la gauche parce que
je pense que mon malgré tout au moins le
travail c'est plus la gauche que la
droite parce que si je sais évidemment
si j'avais des capitaux je voterai la
droite ou préservés mais capitaux mais
j'en ai pas alors c'est la valeur
travail je vote la gauche
le trou normand 18 heures le ton est
encore monté
il y allait même que ce matin plus un
nouvel arrivant
notre voyage se termine là au coeur même
des patients en temps les mecs qui te
traite de fasciste 1 qui te lise
retourne dans ton pays quand est née en
48 1
oui moi je le dis quand il ya des
fascistes comme vous avez un bien fou à
l'endroit des siciliens
vous avez des fascistes qui jouissent de
de retourner dans votre pays alors que
vous avez moins de 4,8
oui je parle de toi est ce que c'est à
dire interrompre et il m'a dit toi dans
mon pays a besoin division gestion et à
plus d' affiner si tard d'une affinité
pendant qu'éric de réduire tourner mais
je n'ai pas eu de rançon et torturé
alors dans tout pays retourne dans son
pays dans leur ai dit voilà je suis donc
fini des aînés en 48 un épilateur armées
françaises
chose que toi tu n'as pas les fragiliser
la chine a fait son oeuvre permet
masculine je n'arrive même pas mal en
pis pour moi la radiale et unsa mais pas
moins non pour moi tu es vraiment un
rigolo non mais tu te permets de de
parler tu permets de parler d'ordre a2
de revenir dans son pays
un tulle en 48 déchu mieux en france de
mère française et de père algérien moi
je suis fier fois comme toi qui étais
pas tardé mombert béni mathar del mar
une humeur bretagne et par ailleurs
breton ouais bah oui aura sur cette
génération vers l'union hainaut vrai on
vous envahit de deux paires en mer si la
bretagne
jamais vous avez réussi à monter jusqu'à
vous avez travaillé
électorale est vrai fascisme oui avec
les fascistes on les a signé le premier
vous avez voulu avoir la tannerie bref
vous avez associé avec la ferme à vous
les bretons j'adore les gourmets